[Music]
i had a dream
i got everything i wanted
not what you'd think billy eilish
delivered a haunting performance of her
grammy-nominated song
everything i wanted on sunday night
billy's brother phineas was also on
stage as she performed on top of a
sunken car
[Music]
it echoes the aesthetic of the music
video for the song which
she directed again
[Music]
during billy's performance we saw harry
styles and heim
watching on ahead of the performance e.t
talked to phineas
he talked about billy's apple tv doc
like everybody's watching it now and
everybody's like
they're commenting on your life right is
that strange
totally yeah i mean reviewing a song
that uh you've written about you know
something you lived through or maybe
something that you didn't that you just
made up is one thing
you're reviewing like a piece of art but
like essentially like reviewing
our households and like our yes
relationship with our mom and dad so
it's very strange
um we're lucky everybody's been super
nice and there's been a lot of
support thrown at our parents which has
been uh
very sweet and an honor because we love
them so much yeah
where do you keep your grammys i keep
them on this shelf
in my living room that's too high for my
dog to knock them over
um but i don't i just we just won this
other one i i was like i don't know
where to put that one because
that shelf is maxed out so i don't know
where to put it